Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ho provato a capire se avesse senso,
e se ne avessi il diritto,
di fare la richiesta
per il riscatto agevolato
degli anni di laurea.
Ho interagito con parecchi uffici,
con diverse modalità:
un chatbot; una video call;
una telefonata;
svariate, svariate e-mail.
Le risposte che ho raccolto
sono tutte molto diverse.
Mi hanno perfino suggerito,
in modi diversi,
come fare a porre la domanda
agli uffici giusti!
Alla fine mi sono rivolta
ad un consulente privato,
che mi ha fornito una risposta
in parziale difformità
con le risposte già collezionate
presso gli uffici.
Ora provate, vi prego, a immaginare con me
se questo stesso dubbio
l'avesse avuto un immigrato.
Ma chi è emigrato?
Sono io, Mariam?
Sono nata in Iran;
ho lasciato il mio paese 13 anni fa;
ho studiato negli Stati Uniti.
ho completato un dottorato
al Politecnico di Milano,
dove ora lavoro come ricercatrice.
Posso considerarmi una emigrata tipo?
Prendiamo uno dei tanti sportivi
che per potere giocare
nelle nazionali di altri paesi
vengono naturalizzati italiani,
tedeschi, francesi.
È uno di loro, l'emigrato tipo?
O forse, l'emigrato tipo
è una di quelle persone
che, senza prospettiva di futuro,
spesso vendono oggetti perstrada?
Oppure, ancora, una persona
che arriva col gommone
sulle coste del nostro paese?
La verità è che tutti noi siamo emigrati.
- Siamo, tutti, immigrati.
Anche io sono un'immigrata,
ogni volta che per qualche giorno in più
trascorro un po' di tempo all'estero.
Siamo tutti immigrati.
E con diversi gradi di difficoltà,
interagiamo con i servizi.
E se falliamo, perdiamo
alcuni dei nostri diritti.
Ed è su questo,
che vorremmo invitarvi a riflettere:
sul ruolo che i servizi svolgono
nel legame tra gli esseri umani
e i loro diritti.
E questo è importante.
E non lo è solo per gli immigrati:
è vero per tutti i cittadini.
Lo facciamo proponendovi tre storie
che ci raccontano tre vicende differenti
di interazione tra cittadini e servizi.
E partiamo proprio da una vicenda
della vita di Mariam.
Io mi sento sempre iraniana.
Sono sposata con un italiano;
abbiamo una figlia;
e pensate, ho pure un passaporto italiano.
Basta, per sentirsi inclusi
e integrati italiani?
Direi proprio di no.
Voglio raccontarvi cosa mi è successo
con il mio conto bancario italiano.
Io e mio marito avevamo un conto
cointestato in una banca,
una banca grande in Italia.
Ma a maggio 2019, improvvisamente,
la banca ci disse
che avrebbe chiuso il conto
in pochissimo tempo.
Fermato. Annullato.
Mai andati in rosso.
Avevamo un prestito aperto,
tutto regolare.
L'unica spiegazione che ci hanno dato era:
ne avevano facoltà, da contratto.
La stessa cosa, nel 2019,
è successa a molti iraniani
con un conto aperto in Italia,
ma succede ancora adesso.
Nei mesi successivi è stato
molto, molto, molto difficile
trovare una banca disposta
ad aprire un conto bancario.
per me, che sono di origine iraniana.
Vi prego di pensare, insieme a me,
se fosse successo a qualcuno di noi.
Ti trovi in un paese straniero,
che ti ha concesso la cittadinanza,
cioè sei in regola.
In questo paese lavori,
hai una casa di proprietà,
un coniuge, una figlia
e paghi le tasse;
e non c'è nessuna banca disposta
ad aprirti un conto?
- In un attimo, mi sono trovata
in una situazione di discriminazione,
di negazione di diritti.
E sì, diritti al plurale.
Non si tratta solo
di non avere un conto bancario:
ma di non ricevere uno stipendio,
di non potere pagare le bollette,
di non potere pagare nei negozi.
Se perdi un diritto,
ne perdi tanti altri a cascata.
- La seconda storia che vi proponiamo
è quella di Oren Yiftakhel,
un professore israeliano di chiara fama,
invitato come visiting professor
presso il Politecnico di Milano.
Oren era già stato tre volte
al consolato italiano, a Ber Sheva,
per ottenere - perché lui l'ha avuto -
il timbro sul passaporto,
con su scritto "visto per lavoro"
prima di venire in Italia.
Giunto in Italia, non ha potuto firmare
il contratto con il Politecnico di Milano
perché il visto andava completato,
andava regolarizzata la procedura.
E stato tantissime volte
in Questura, in Prefettura;
e le informazioni che gli hanno fornito
sono state sempre incomplete,
date un po' alla volta, mai troppo chiare.
La vicenda si è conclusa:
Oren è ritornato in Israele,
e il visto sul passaporto
non è stato ancora verificato.
- Ora andiamo in Grecia,
in un centro di accoglienza.
Fatima e suo marito sono siriani;
Fatima è incinta, e deve partorire.
Ma lei non vuole andare in ospedale.
Perché?
Perché lei non sa che è suo diritto.
Anche lei è irregolare,
in base all'Articolo Due
della Dichiarazione Universale
dei Diritti Umani.
Alla fine, Fatima dà alla luce un bimbo
nel centro di accoglienza.
Dopo pochi giorni,
con un dipendente comunale,
arriva la dichiarazione di nascita.
Problema: ci sono tre lingue di mezzo.
Il formulario è scritto
con l'alfabeto greco;
viene compilato con alfabeto latino;
però Fatima è siriana,
e la sua madrelingua usa l'alfabeto arabo.
Controlla come viene scritto
il nome di Muadh,
e anche il nome di suo padre e sua madre.
Così, Muhad viene registrato
con un nome sbagliato.
E sono sbagliati
anche i nomi dei genitori.
Come va a finire?
Fatima e suo marito, sulla carta,
non hanno un figlio.
E Muhad -
che si chiamerà, anagraficamente, Mouhà -
sulla carta, non ha genitori!
- Noi ci abbiamo provato: siamo ottimisti.
Ci abbiamo provato con un progetto europeo
intitolato "easyRights":
servizi facili, anzi diritti facili.
Siamo ottimisti, come vi ho detto.
"easyRights" considera,
dà per scontato, parte dall'idea
che i servizi sono interfacce
fra esseri umani e diritti.
Ha ragionato con queste storie,
ha ragionato con queste persone,
ha ragionato su queste situazioni
e ha dedotto che è importante
che questi servizi lavorino bene;
perché se non funzionano bene,
queste interfacce,
di fatto allontanano
le persone dai loro diritti.
E questo è molto grave,
se accade a quelle persone
che già vedono i loro diritti frustrati,
negati in modo sistematico
nei paesi dai quali scappano.
Migliorare l'interazione
tra immigrati e servizi
è stato lo scopo di "easyRights",
un progetto che ha lavorato
al miglioramento delle interfacce
con soluzioni tecnologiche
di facilitazione di uso,
e di guida ai servizi.
In easyRights, noi abbiamo
costruito un chatbot
che usa un sistema
di Intelligenza Artificiale
per leggere i documenti amministrativi
e ricostruire le procedure
che poi presenta all'utente.
Il chatbot consente all'immigrato
di accedere ad alcuni tool
che lo aiutano a familiarizzare
con la lingua del paese ospitante,
e propone un esercizio
di vocabolario e pronuncia
dedicati alla procedura
che deve affrontare.
In easyRights, abbiamo fatto anche altro.
Abbiamo costruito uno standard
di qualità dei servizi
che in questo momento
è in corso di formalizzazione
presso il CEN, l'ente europeo
di standardizzazione.
Abbiamo chiamato questo standard
"Mediation Grammar".
L'abbiamo chiamato così
perché lo standard propone,
per l'appunto, una grammatica
che prova a garantire una qualità minima
nella mediazione tra esseri umani
e i loro diritti.
Una qualità minima,
per l'appunto, dei servizi.
Questo standard lavora su tre componenti.
La prima è quella
dell'attualizzazione dei diritti,
perché non debba mai succedere
che, vistosi negato un diritto,
un cittadino se ne veda
negati tanti altri:
l'abbiamo imparato
con la storia di Mariam.
Il secondo componente si chiama
"Adeguatezza Informativa".
I servizi devono essere forniti
con procedure e anche linee guida
chiare, complete, accessibili a tutti.
Perché non può capitare
che un professore universitario,
che parla quattro lingue diverse,
che ha già completato
l'80% di una procedura
nel Paese di provenienza,
non riesca a fare l'ultimo passo
in tre mesi e mezzo.
E infine, l'accessibilità linguistica:
non ci possiamo permettere il lusso
di disgregare una famiglia
perché la lingua parlata,
e quella scritta,
in un'interlocuzione non corrispondono.
Molti cittadini
sono in guerra con i servizi.
È un po' esagerata,
questa frase: però è la verità.
Se questi servizi non funzionano bene,
noi neghiamo diritti:
speriamo di averlo chiarito,
questo concetto.
Un beneficio che costruiamo
per gli immigrati
non è esclusivo per gli immigrati,
se lavoriamo bene con i servizi:
costruiamo migliore accessibilità
ai servizi, ai diritti,
anche agli altri cittadini.
E garantiamo il diritto
ad un lavoro sereno
anche a chi quei servizi li fornisce.
"Amore incondizionato per l'essere umano"
rischia di essere una frase retorica,
se noi non creiamo le condizioni
per far sì che a tutti le persone
sia assicurato l'esercizio
dei propri diritti.
Per noi, questo amore si sostanzia
nelle condizioni socio-tecniche -
i servizi, appunto -
che devono esser progettati e forniti
in modo che siano ridotti all'osso
gli ostacoli tra i cittadini
e i loro diritti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)